من المهم حقًا بالنسبة
للمرضى وللناس بشكل عام معرفة
أعدادهم لأن هذا ما يتيح
لهم حقًا معرفة ما
هي مخاطر القلب والأوعية الدموية الأساسية لديهم ، فلنبدأ
بضغط الدم أو قوة الدم
في الشرايين حيث أن قلبك ينبض
ويكون ضغط الدم المثالي هو  ما
يقرب من 120 فوق 80 ، ولكن هناك
أحدث الإرشادات التي تقول أن بعض
المرضى قد يكون من المعقول أن
يكون لديهم ضغط دم يتراوح بين 130 إلى 140
ملم من الزئبق فوق 80 إلى 89 ،
الرقم الثاني الذي يجب معرفته هو مؤشر كتلة الجسم
وهذا رقم  يمكن
حسابها بناءً على طولك ووزنك ،
المجموعة الثالثة من الأرقام التي تحتاج
إلى معرفتها هي مستوى الجلوكوز في الدم
أو كمية السكر في مجرى الدم
، ويمكن أن يعلمك هذا الرقم إذا كنت
مصابًا بمرض السكري أو إذا كنت في  خطر الإصابة
بمرض السكري وأخيرًا
الكوليسترول عندما تحصل على
فحص الكوليسترول في مكتب الطبيب ،
سترى أربعة أرقام
تعود أولاً  سيكون الرقم هو
أن إجمالي الكوليسترول لديك ومن الناحية المثالية
يجب أن يكون أقل من 200 في
الدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا ميريديث وود